for the last 16 days nicaragua's police
had prevented matagalpa's bishop orlando
alvarez from leaving his residence not
even to preside over mass
siempre always the road in front of our
diocese is closed and blocked by the
national police
but that was not the end of it before
dawn friday police raided the bishops
residents detained lay priests and staff
and put bishop alvarez under house
arrest
in a statement the police called it
quote in operation to recover normality
for citizens and families of matagalpa
accusing bishop rolando alvarez of
repeated acts of destabilization and
provocations
with the vast majority of government
opponents in prison or in exile
nicaragua's catholic church has become a
thorn in the side of president daniel
ortega and his wife rosario murillo who
is the vice president the presidential
couple accused the bishop of instigating
dissent ever since they gave refuge to
anti-government protesters during
widespread demonstrations in 2018
human rights organizations are again
raising their voice and demanding the
release of those arbitrarily detained
the secretary general is very concerned
by the severe closure of democratic and
civic space in nicaragua and recent
actions against civil society
organizations including those of the
catholic church
reports of arrayed against the residents
of the catholic bishop of matagalpa only
heighten these concerns
bishop alvarez is the fourth priest to
be put under house arrest in as many
months
this is incredible repression against
the church and repression against
catholic people but we remain here
praying to the virgin mary
shortly after the bishop's arrest a
group of latin american and european
statesmen called on pope francis to
break his silence and speak out forcibly
against what they call ortega's
persecution of the catholic church
lucian newman al jazeera